and folks you know as you guys go  through this uh journey with myself and  and and us here valuetainment pb podcast  i'm simply a regular guy that's curious  and wants to learn and i ask the  questions and i want to know what the  hell is going on so if you're somebody  that's also curious and sometimes maybe  i'm asking a question that you're  thinking about  we appreciate your support and sometimes  i may ask a question that you're not  thinking about or i might ask a question  make a comment that you don't agree with  but the purpose of this podcast is for  this course  and many times i'll be wrong many times  we'll challenge the guests like we did  today and many times we'll be right and  many times the guests will be right but  regardless we will all leave hopefully  thinking saying huh that was an  interesting conversation that i was a  part of earlier today on the podcast